25 ans d'une association résumer en
quatre cents pages pour un sourire
d'enfant raconte l'histoire de cette
association humanitaire fondée par un
couple marie france et christian des
pallières tout jeune retraité ils se
rendent au cambodge à phnom penh en 1995
là bas ils découvrent une décharge à
ciel ouvert où des centaines d'enfants y
travaillent c'est dit voilà on peut pas
on ne peut pas laisser ça il faut faire
quelque chose on a commencé petit à
petit un pas devant l'autre sans savoir
où on allait vous m'auriez dit à cette
époque là où il en serait aujourd'hui je
me dis attendez vous êtes fous on a en
fait c'est de répondre aux besoins au
fur et à mesure qu'ils se présentaient
tout bêtement marie-france des pallières
a donc voulu coucher par écrit ses
mémoires
elle était en dédicace à la librairie
des lacs au vésinet l'association compte
désormais quatre écoles qui regroupe 21
une formation six mille cinq cents
enfants qui sont scolarisés dans les
programmes et 5500 enfants qui ont pu
trouver un métier l'engagement est en
forme et auquel on tient qui est de les
accompagner jusqu'à un métier et donc ça
passe par rapport à pages couleurs pour
ceux qui en trois quatre cinq années de
retard ceux qui n'ont pas trop de retard
et sont scolarisés en écoles publiques
en fournit aux familles de
de quoi compenser le manque à gagner de
ce que nous en rapporte plus en
travaillant la fondatrice de
l'association restera six mois en france
l'occasion de découvrir ses lecteurs qui
sont généralement aussi donateurs de
l'association plus que
ces prêts
oui c'est très émouvant fait de
rencontrer tout ce qu'on a vu là bas ici
enfin qui ont fait des choses qui nous
suivent sur mercredi 8 décembre marie
france des pallières sera en dédicace à
la librairie gibert joseph à versailles